[Music]
welcome back Findlay Subaru of Las Vegas
the sponsors of this next segment have
been serving the Las Vegas Community for
over 50 years I stopped by the lot to
see how they continue to give back to
the community and to see which car
should be at the top of your wish list
this year
[Music]
well the lot is full here at Subaru of
Las Vegas which is always a good sign
but there is definitely one car that has
caught my eye not just because of the
color but I've been hearing really great
things about it so we got to bring in
our friend general manager Burton Hughes
to tell us all about it so great to see
you Burton good to see you Julian so
tell me about this car I love the color
it reminds me of pumpkin spice but
there's a lot of great features in it
yes this is the brand new 2022 Subaru
WRX and it has the Subaru performance
transmission it is amazing paddle
shifters you can have so much fun kind
of like you're driving an F1 car yeah I
was going to say it reminds me of a
sporty car but what I love about
everything here at Subaru you guys are
really big into safety tell us how safe
this car is and some of those features
well believe it or not this model does
get the highest safety rating that you
can possibly get of course Subaru is
known for that we have more HS top
safety pick plus Awards than any other
manufacturer and it's just an amazing
car I think you'll love it you need to
be driving it I know I was thinking I
could see myself driving this around our
streets here in Vegas so people come in
looking for a car how would you kind of
sell them on this or what would you tell
them about it to really get them excited
well obviously symmetrical all-wheel
drive is something that Subarus come
with so you have the the the safety on
the road as far as the handling is
concerned you can kind of go places that
other cars can't go you have the safety
you've got act a good economy and you
know it's a Subaru and it's all about
love and you're going to fall in love
with it speaking of people coming into
the store here your customer service is
Top Notch how do you guys kind of
describe your services and what you
offer in here everything is just so
honest and happy and carefree in here
when you when you come here I think
you're going to find that the
non-commissioned sales the environment
is really really relaxed we have a great
Cafe to just hang out even if you don't
end up buying a car get yourself a free
cup of coffee but you know what we have
stress-free pricing all the cars are
Market priced uh it is it's not the
typical car buying experience well on
top of all of that you guys are so great
about giving back to the community tell
us what you have planned for this month
well it's mental health awareness month
and we are donating to Hope Means Nevada
every single car new or used that is
leased or purchased uh is going to have
fifty dollars donated for each car to
Hope means about it and then also on our
oil changes three dollars for every oil
service is going to go towards hope
means a bath and on top of all of that
you also give back to the schools and
children in the community kind of
piggybacking off of Nevada reading week
yes we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
be collecting books all month long for
Nevada reading week new and gently used
books so bring them on in and let's get
those into the hands of the kids so
basically come in check out the WRX
donate those books it's all just all in
one here you guys are like a family and
as a final wrap up what do you want
people to feel when they walk away from
their experience here at Subaru of Las
Vegas love I want you to feel the love
truly it is it's what makes us so
different and and just know that we're
going to be honest we're going to be
transparent you're going to enjoy the
experience Finley has been a Subaru
retailer for over 50 years we've been
here and we'll be here
segment you can give them a call at
702-495-2100 or visit Subaru of
lasvegas.com they have a special offer
2.9 financing for 48 months for
well-qualified buyers we'll be right
back